okay we've got a voicemail audience
question this week take a listen to this
one that came in hi my name is hunter
and I'm from Nebraska the red stay in
Nebraska I'm just wondering if either
you or Patrick had to choose what the
red state of living which one would it
be
thank you yeah I am interpreting the
question as which red state could you
live in assuming you can choose where in
that red state you would live and for me
it's very clear I know you know what I'm
gonna say right Pat you're gonna stay
Austin Texas or you know maybe Asheville
North Carolina one of those absolutely
incorrect I am going to say I would
choose the red state of Florida and as
wacky and and unorganized and lacking
infrastructure as Florida is I would
live in Miami Miami I would say is my
favorite red state city in the country
you're gonna call Florida a red state I
think it's still up for grabs I think
it's a purple state voted for Obama
twice after all right I still call
Florida a red state because despite the
occasional democratic presidential vote
the state legislature is very right and
big picture it's a it's a right-wing
it's a right-wing state and I would if
forced to live in a red state 100% go to
Miami
yeah Miami's not a bad pick if we're
gonna qualify that as a red state I
think I would go with maybe Montana or
Wyoming I will just go completely off
the grid you know get rid of the city
living type thing I've been doing for a
while enjoy the national parks out there
live in my own it would be a whole new
look for me I'm sure if you did that you
would no longer be vegan because you
would capture your own game right yeah I
mean that would be part of the lifestyle
yeah yeah oh yeah all right well
everything that would go to Montana or
Wyoming I would go to Miami Florida
certainly could not be more different in
terms of personality as far as that goes
on the bonus show today we will talk
about Congressman Jim Jordan being
accused of ignoring allegations of
sexual abuse while coaching wrestling at
Ohio State we will talk about the
untimely passing of former MSNBC host ed
Schultz at age 64 and we will also talk
about stormy Daniels attorney Michael
avenatti saying that he might challenge
Donald Trump
for president in 2020 what is that all
about those stories and more on today's
bonus show two ways to access it become
a member at join pakman.com or become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show